-Did you ever realize
that you were gonna be a --
I mean, you've had
such a great career,
but you make people
have the good cries.
-Yeah.
So, I started with
"A Walk to Remember"
when I was 16.
-"A walk to Remember."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
-Look at that.
I mean, is that --
-Little baby Mandy.
-I know, baby Mandy.
-Baby Mandy.
-You're still baby Mandy,
please.
But do people come up to you
and go like,
"I love that movie,
and that was how I met..."?
-That movie has touched people
and still continues to
in a way that, like,
we never, ever expected.
I'm totally flattered.
I'm slightly flabbergasted that,
like, the sort of things
in my career that I'm most known
for are making people cry.
-No, but no --
[ Laughter ]
-I never would have guessed that
in a million years.
-No, and sing and dance.
I mean, come on.
What are you talking about?
But I thought it would be
kind of fun if we played a game
where I will say a quote from
either "A Walk to Remember"...
-Mm-hmm.
-...or "This Is Us."
-Okay.
-And you try to guess
which one it's from.
But not necessarily you.
Just in the movie
or in the show.
-Okay.
-And these are quotes from --
Yeah.
-If I don't pass this quiz,
that doesn't really
bode well for me.
It means I'm unprofessional
or something
that I don't people's lines.
-It doesn't mean that at all.
Either way, you win in this.
You ready?
-Okay.
-Can I get James --
Maybe some piano music,
like a romantic...
-Romantic.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-I like it.
-All right, ready?
-Yeah.
-"You have to promise
you won't fall in love with me."
[ Laughter ]
-That's definitely
"A Walk to Remember."
-Yeah, it is
"A Walk to Remember"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
I know you can't look at me.
-I was like, "Okay."
-I love you can't even look
at my face without laughing.
-I'll promise.
-This is who I am.
My romantic-comedy career
went south fast.
[ Laughter ]
All right. Ready?
♪♪
[ Light laughter ]
"I thought
I saw something in you --
something good --
but I was very wrong."
-Oh, see, I bought that.
-You did?
That was, like, really good?
That was close?
-Oof!
I felt it.
-You did?
-I felt it, yeah.
-That's also
"A Walk to Remember."
-It is "A Walk to Remember"!
Very good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You celebrate.
This one, I got you.
-Okay.
-This one's a little bit
more emotional,
so maybe hype it up
a little bit with emotion.
Help me out here.
Yeah, that's good.
♪♪
"For the past 16 years,
I have put everything
and everyone ahead of myself!"
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Come on!
You're supposed to fall for it.
-That's "This Is Us."
-That is "This Is Us"!
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right.
I'll do one more.
-Please, I love this.
-My acting's terrible.
I'll do one more.
-I just want an entire hour
of this.
-All right, here's my last one.
All right, here we go.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
First of all, that already --
Why would I a paw the actor?
Like...
[ Laughter ]
"I can't go back to who I was...
before I met you."
That's it.
-That is Jack in "This Is Us."
-Yeah, it is.
I wish I was Jack.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Milo, I'm sorry!
-[ Laughs ]
You pulled it off.
-Nah, I didn't.
He's so --
You guys are so good.
But can we say
what happens in the season?
We show, like, the beginning
of your relationship.
-Yes.
The Jack and Rebecca courtship
is sort of what gets explored
for the first half
of the season.
So it's fun.
I feel like I get to smile
and laugh and enjoy myse--
I have cried all the tears
humanly possible
last season, so...
-Isn't that interesting?
So, the young you is, like,
the "falling in love" you.
-Yeah.
-But then you could do --
Are you doing middle you
and older you?
-I will still do present-day,
and we're also, of course,
juxtaposing the sort of
lovesick, like, you know,
courtship days
of Jack and Rebecca
with, like, the time period
right after Jack passed away.
-I don't know how you do it.
-Yeah.
-But you really balance it.
-Thanks.
-It's actually so fantastic.
-Thanks, Jimmy.
-You just got to know
how great you are.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Mandy Moore
and Milo Ventimiglia in the new
season of "This Is Us."
Take a look at this.
-Did you see the game?
-Pfft! Insane.
-Thank you.
-You didn't want anything?
-No. I'm okay.
-Oh.
-Yeah.
-Okay. Thanks.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Mmm.
What?
-You, uh...
You got something on --
-What?
-Well, it's a piece of candy.
-Can you get it?
-May I?
-Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you.
[ Chuckles ]
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Aww!
We're all freaking out.